hey guys hey that's ugly [ __ ] you been
decided how are you great come in ice
why thank you
seeing you do it you [ __ ] Superman
thank you better
what's your name is Kevin Rempel Kevin
thanks so much I was like I saw the
ferret the carpet on the Fairmont Royal
York yes you're here I don't like what
is it [ __ ] on so if I see you dude
Thank You Man
great timing for the love curry I'm real
I think he loved you glad you made it so
much I wish you well brother thanks
brother and we should my words to you
later
[Music]
[Applause]
take care good luck Congrats
Gary are you such a pleasure how are
things
[Music]
[Music]
what a great sign okay it's so awesome
it's basically it's everything I believe
in meaning it's how I do public speaking
it's why one on Twitter it's all
shareable like look you know for me it
really won cuz that's basically how I
always lived my life anyway so that made
it easy yes but that's it but it's show
but it's shareable because word of mouth
it has infrastructure it's called social
media and word of mouth is how
everything actually works you know
nobody no brand has ever spent enough
money to reach every person they've
reached enough people that created the
word of mouth to then force other people
to look for it like I genuinely feel
like I'm playing a different bizarro
game than everybody on earth I'm not
kidding I just think I'm navigating and
the way I see it is like a different
color than everybody else is seeing it
mainly because I think I have two things
real life talent and real life patients
I think the people that have the biggest
skills have the ability to not screw the
other person over every time they're not
fighting for every inch because they
know they have it and that is that self
you know somewhere this comes in all
sorts of shapes and sizes self-awareness
is noble and sounds good in the way
we've positioned so far you also have to
get into a weird place where like if
you're lucky enough itself have
self-awareness and you're good at
something you start getting into a real
place of ego it's a real thing and and
look of course I'd like to think it's
confidence cuz it surely is but I have
to be empathetic that I'm about to take
the stage and have a sense of aura and
bravado around me that if people don't
like what I'm saying or if people don't
like the way I'm saying it it's real
easy to go down the ego path and I'm and
I understand
the rock we do a quick meet up in
Toronto how's it going so far
good so you've had a very successful
career and a lot of challenges along the
way
how do you approach a challenge I like
challenges you know I'm much more into
the journey I look at challenges as the
narratives of my career you know the
book will be very boring if everything
is easy you know you need the arc and so
when I see challenges you know I don't
think that you get to have the luxuries
that come along with being a leader or
CEO or a founder if I've want this if I
want the attention if I want the fruits
I have to be respectful that the
challenges come along with it I
genuinely love the scene in the movie
the cliche scene where the person gets
punched in the mouth you know turns
blood comes out spits out his tooth and
then looks back at the other person like
now what if I was really talking to an
entrepreneur just starting out first I
would challenge them if they actually
are an entrepreneur or they're
attractive to the current state of
entrepreneurship which is I'm blown away
by the fact that this has all happened
you know I grew up at a time where a
business man and woman was just a normal
profession this Rockstar status this
pedestal that the entrepreneur has been
put on I benefited from it but I'll tell
you that one of the things that I want
to speak more about is there's a lot
more suicide and depression in our world
than has been bubbled up I've had some
acquaintances commit suicide because
they were not true entrepreneurs and
when the adversity hit they didn't know
how to deal with it because everybody
thinks everybody's winning in our world
and so I would I would tell them to know
themselves to make sure they're doing it
for the right reasons I think that the
entrepreneurs that I grew up with in the
90s and early 2000s these were people
that couldn't breathe if they weren't
doing their thing they weren't chasing
the headlines or the money it was their
natural state and I would I would tell
them a lot about the shortcomings of
entrepreneurship which is it's quite
lonely you get judged a lot
and I would poke and prod to make sure
that they had the stomach for it because
if you don't in its current state the
market tells you everything's rosy and
it's phenomenal it's the only way
and unfortunately 99% of people going to
fail I think I think I think one is
empowered when they are a complete peace
with their decision making
it is stunning to me how not scared I am
about anything I do nothing I because I
think that when you're intent if you are
able to push your intent to a pretty
pure place and let me explain what I
mean by this
I'm not [ __ ] some Sherpa mother
teresa type character here here's here's
what I think I am I think I believe in I
think I believe in
you know meritocracy and the game and if
you were better than me I'm pumped for
you see I think the problem is so many
people want to win at somebody else's
expense without understanding that
there's so many variations of winning
and every one of us has a totally
different definition for it
and so from me this has been so easy
this journey because my intent is pure I
want to build the biggest [ __ ]
building in town I want to win number
one most money most impact best that's
looking you know whatever all that but I
want to do it by actually doing it I
want to build the biggest building by
building the biggest building I see way
too many people wanting to build the
biggest building by tearing everybody
else's buildings down so I feel
empowered because I feel like it comes
with the place I'm gonna suffocate the
seven or eight principles that I believe
in on you for as long as you pay
attention to me and I will never change
I'm gonna bore the living [ __ ] out of
you because there's only so many things
that actually work they're just not that
attractive especially right now when
everybody thinks it's so easy thank you
I think everybody wants the stuff it's
just the problem is it's hard work and
you have to give up leisure family time
but you have to give [ __ ] up and a lot
of people are just hardwired to want
those things we all know there's no
one-size-fits-all right there's a lot of
parents there's so many parents that
gave their kids nothing so much so much
more is hardwiring than we'd like to
think I think it's a basic again black
and white thing because the child want
to climb the mountain or do they want to
run in the total opposite direction and
some of it it and probably quite a bit
of it is a DNA game if I'm able to pull
off and meet up it's gonna be around 11
p.m. or so I would say realistically
[Music]
so well
you're not sama Osama how are you good
how'd you guys how'd you guys find this
do you really want to know yes snapchat
Instagram but what I put out
yeah what's the pitch other restaurants
and you figured it out went on Google
Maps no every single restaurant Hey all
right yeah how are you hi
I saw your Greyhound picture that's
[ __ ] crazy man where are you coming
from
I'm coming from what to do and how far
away is that it's like hey man how are
you man thank you didn't get a chance to
go to the conference you're like I know
that in saga awesome well cool you wanna
take a quick photo I knew you guys were
waiting yes I need to get back into my
meeting I'm actually I actually did post
this stuff just now but I'm going I'm
going back in for at least 15 minutes
and then I'll go check I would feel like
in 15 minutes maybe somebody'll show up
so I'll see you guys a little bit if
you're here
yeah I'm coming up hey guys
[Applause]
Gary I'm Marty Marty CSUN how I say
thank you you and Casey from New York
have inspired me I'm sure a lot of
people thank you brother
beyond these be real be honest and just
work hard hey man just can't thank you
enough for that
thank you guys have one question yep as
a hustler is it okay to take a day off
every week of course I take I take four
I take four hours off every Sunday in
the fall
of course I mean look my big thing and I
think it's good to have you guys here
for clarity I'm not so worried if you
take four days off I'm just worried
about what you do when you're on like I
always tell people like I want people
like one thing that's why I did the
Arianna Huffington episode I want people
to sleep like I sleep like sleep is
important
I sleep 5 or 6 or 7 hours not 1 or 2
like people get caught up in like the
romantic point of view of these things
like we're all different
the punchline though is if you're
complaining and you aren't working as
hard as you possibly can that's the
problem every one of these questions
that you're all gonna ask is super
personal like you know what I mean like
what I'm gonna tell you like it's three
weeks and four days that's gorgeous you
know what I mean I think the punchline
is I'll say it again I just don't
understand if you're complaining what
like that you don't understand that what
the work ethic is the variable no it's
not even about complaining it's just
like
putting a certain amount of hustle
before you up the right horse knife nope
like I think it's I think work is
variable but like your ambition may be
dramatically different than mine your
your variables may be different like
it's why I'm trying to put so much
context around my content because it's
dangerous to have one size fits all
there's so many variables in this circle
everybody's got their own [ __ ] the only
thing that I just keep pounding is too
many people [ __ ] complain and then
too many people confused why they're not
winning and so much of it has to do with
their work ethic so but if you're good
like me or your mom or [ __ ] the Lord
is it shouldn't tell you how to do it
like the [ __ ] that I talk about I
believe I'm so grateful the thought that
a human being could get emotional about
meeting me or just desperately wants the
document meeting me is something that I
struggle not thinking is the coolest
thing I like so my big belief is that
money and fame only accelerate and
expose who you actually are
well that was a productive trip in
Toronto a very efficient we hustled big
fan of Toronto really good day great
conference a lot of business development
just really uh really intrigued by I've
always loved this city I've always been
a big fan of Toronto just really good
excited about the future
you got it
[Music]